on this episode India turns into junk I
mean dunk
[Music]
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B god I just I because I did
Wine Library TV last I don't remember
the intro everybody this is Gary
Vaynerchuk in the steps of 224 of the
askgaryvee show I got it Jesus right
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 2 24 of the ask gary vee
show tuck i want you to keep I want you
to keep that little thing we just did
right before this show that's right I am
that rusty that I couldn't even remember
how to intro this show we've been on a
major hiatus in general I feel like when
we made the switch from DeMaio to Tyler
on the assistant front Tyler hasn't
prioritized this show as much as we've
needed dunk so hopefully we'll get back
into a great rhythm one of the maybe
this is the third or fourth show in the
new office that makes me happy and and
India has transformed into a
good-looking young Swedish boy yep dunk
tell him who you are real quick
vaynernation my name is Elliot Robinson
otherwise known as dunk 18 years old I'm
some sweet meta it goes for the
askgaryvee show today very cool duncan I
interacted on snapchat and Instagram
where he did some great work under his
dunk account I met him for five minutes
he flew from Sweden to London when I was
there i sat with him for 5-10 minutes
and I said I need this kid to work with
me in the United States of America and I
was here before that I knew that you
didn't need all sorts of legal papers
that was like that's how committed I was
I was like whatever these overheads are
I'm gonna cover them because I believe
in you so much and by the way he has
made an impact even AJ who's really
tough I think every I'm very optimistic
and thing everybody's really talented
age is like what's up this dumb kid I'm
like alright Vayner sports relax all
right let's do it dunk now listen for
all the great things that you bring I do
not think you're gonna do this well I
have a feeling that you're not gonna do
a good job but let's see how pleased I
am cares alright see I know you're
charismatic first version yes right I
are both
very criminals experience well you ready
screwed up you're supposed to say the
person's name and he says anonymous this
way is that true yeah
interesting okay keep going my friend
and I recently started working for an
app startup the person who manages
digital marketing is inexperienced and
in our opinion stunting potential room
we are looking for an opportunity to
show our talent to execs without
overstepping our boundaries how can we
show that we are better for the world
the execs exit I feel like this is
actually your question and you don't
believe in Andy and that this is not
real this is more you projecting your
opinions about what's going on here yeah
yeah listen I think I think much like
what goes on here and this is why it's
funny and this is for the whole team I
think we've got a good situation so many
of you don't my vice here is what I do
think we create more of you looks funny
I create a company where you can start
hacking and doing things you know that
you can do that but it's your own trying
to be nice to whomever that may hurt
that's supposed to be doing it that
holds it back so this is a really
fascinating thing of vaynermedia I've
created a world where I never want
people to not show if you can show it
you know then you can do it then just do
it show that person now the tough part
of that advice is let me give you a
great scenario in this exact scenario
where there's a lot of people my team
that are talented and everybody's got
different roles and a lot of people are
mismatched into different
responsibilities some that aren't even
their best skillset versus other things
that other people are doing they start
liking each other like my team Jenna I
mean they don't all have to be the best
of best friends but you guys genuinely
like each other and so what's really
holding it back is not hurting that
other person's feelings of why are you
going into my territory it's very
complicated I mean look you're the most
part of this this is much like life it's
just a black and white answer either you
step and run through the china shop and
show your skills and take the risk of
saying here and by the way there's a
good way and a bad way to do it my real
answer would be to go to the person that
is doing that role and saying I really
believe in myself in this craft I know
this is your role I know I'm in
accounting and you're the creative
director but can you help me show you
or give me the ear cover to show Gary
that I can do this because here's how
it's gonna play out either that's what's
going to happen or I'm going to quit and
leave here and go do it somewhere else
and I want us to be teammates not
adversaries now eight this is a big
number eight out of ten times that
person is going to try to hold down the
other person out of insecurity fear all
these things but you might get lucky and
it might be one of those two out of ten
times that's my favorite way to do it
because I think that's the only middle
step to the black and white thing which
is to answer the question show somebody
like edited episode of daily bean be
like told you other time better than you
like just do it
or don't and be miserable and let a
little kernel of negativity eventually
become cancer and it's going to end up
with you underperforming getting fired
or you quitting I think that's the
punchline of all of this all the things
I talk about to not suppress are
predicated on the outcomes going to be
the outcome anyway so why not just speed
it up but with humility so like I get
away with a lot of stuff because I get
to the punchline but I coat it with as
much honey and humility so that it
becomes swallowable consumable would
have been a better way to go next video
question from jan-jan I want to ask
because you don't do it often but from
time to time you mentioned China we chat
the other internet and stuff like that
so do you actually spend time on
studying these things how they work how
they are different and if so what do you
focus on and have you learned something
already that you are applying in your
business or that you are sharing with
the clients in the Uni in the US and all
around the world so thank you very much
for the grant thank you very much for
answering my question and have a great
day bye Chad great question and I'm
really dying to see if you guys I feel
like you guys are being very smart and
asked that question something very funny
happened two days ago yesterday
yesterday right yesterday I sent a team
wide email about this was I guess rated
two days ago yesterday yesterday I sent
an email to my entire team
and it said China it's time let's start
transcribing my content it's time to get
serious Jan uh so the answer is the
other internet China is something I'm
very very passionate and a believer of
on a religious level but I've never gone
to church meaning I know it's right I
know it's big I know the biggest
consumer set in the world is there but
you can't get to everything and much
like there's a lot of things I'm not
doing well even within the US I've not
been able to open up that can of worms
vaynermedia eventually is going to play
in that market it will have to as we're
becoming a global leader and so no
question the thing I'm most disappointed
about on a micro level in my career over
the last thirty six months is that I
haven't forced myself to spend four or
five separate trips in China taste it
get used to it and really articulate a
real strategy literally literally I
became so fed up with myself that
yesterday I sent to the team it's time
for me to become a player in that market
and so I'm sure that's why the question
was asked or maybe it's just
serendipitous but the answer is no I
have not spent time analyzing the we
chats pencils on the rest of the market
but it is is something I better get
around to if I have to expand on the
aspirations that I have and I think both
vaynermedia and me as a brand have
enormous opportunities within that
market I think we fit the mold on an
entrepreneurial level and so I'm excited
about the next frontier Oh next is a
video question from Diogo Silva okay hey
Gary I'm yoga I'm from Portugal and have
a very simple question to ask you are
you good with names are you able to
remember every single employer and
people you do business with names and
how important is that skill for your
business thank you Gary for instance
episode I feel like this episode you
know what I feel like since we haven't
had a lot of time that there's been a
whole lot of work I'm very intrigued by
this episode I am terrible with names
it's devastating I have so much pride
and I know that people that watch
dailyvee are probably surprised by how
many names I know but there's so many
names I don't
and I don't know names of like 18 months
in clients and I don't know names of
like people that you know like I'm it's
unbelievable how much context I know but
names I don't meaning there's employees
here that I know like things that are
going on with like the well-being of
their relationship because I follow them
on social and like follow their
boyfriend and then like figure out like
oh you know like literally literally
like indefinitely no their performance
and remember that they had a bad day or
recall this or just deep deep deep stuff
but I'm like it's a Karen or Susan like
it's super tough for me it's something
I'm very bad at and it is not it's very
important people like here's what I
think tactically it's important and
people would be disappointed if they've
been paying vaynermedia for two years
and their important client and I don't
know their name I understand that what I
what overrides that while I feel great
is that's the tactic to the thing that
matters which is knowing one's name is a
one version of caring about that person
I know how much I care and though I hate
that the easiest version of that is not
something I have a skill for it's all
the other stuff that I have skills for
that make up for that vulnerability
because that is a surface level
vulnerability not a deep vulnerability
and so I think at a macro level it is
stunningly unimportant what it perceives
to mean is the most important thing but
tactically I don't think so on a micro
level sure it's important you like that
answer
I like this can I hose hey Gary I'm Ryan
in a video with Joe polish you said that
you could sell rocks on the street and
still make 100 grand a year is that true
if so could you make a video where you
sell a rock to someone who doesn't know
you
Thanks so Ryan theoretically it is true
practically listen the truth is actually
I'm surprised I'm answering this I think
I can make a hundred thousand dollars a
year selling like I wish I was in a
point in my life where I could be so
crazy and right now off of this do it go
with the rock
to some crazy place where nobody knows
who I am which oh by the way and I love
you all for this which is almost
everywhere
I like down the street but you know go
to a place where I'm not me and I know
that you trust me you guys perceive me
bigger than I am I'm just me and I think
now look here's what I would do I go to
place first I go to a rich upper-middle
class area where where it's not too rich
but upper-middle class demo and I would
set up shop on the corner of the street
and I guess most of my day would be in
have to have rocks in the general area
like access to rocks you know which is
everyone oh I'll tell you what I
understand but like if I'm trying to
make a hundred thousand like and I can
pick anywhere like you might as well if
there's a perfect zip code where it's
got the right income level that I want
and there's access to it from an
efficiency standpoint I know I could buy
him on the internet and all that stuff
but nonetheless I guess I would try to
market myself as somebody who is
creative on top of a rock so I don't
think I would if I was selling a rock I
wouldn't try to sell you a rock because
that wouldn't work but what I would do
is I would doodle and create on top of
rocks and try to sell them
and I genuinely with my entire heart
believe that I can make a hundred
thousand dollars a year in year to firm
in year one I would make thirty six
thousand dollars in profit I believe is
awful sell just arrived it is but I
think what I would do because I want to
get to a hundred thousand is the
doodling on top would then constitute
his art and that becomes agnostic and
then marketing can take over and then
all I need to do is have Leonardo
DiCaprio take a picture on his Instagram
that he's bought this rock because it's
art and then it's game over
it's just high school arbitrage all of
it is all right next question is from
Bay oh baby yeah awesome
so Gary you're so successful you run a
100 million dollar revenue company how
do you stay hungry period Betty I think
that a truth is I think a lot of us are
hardwired I think because I didn't come
from much because I didn't speak the
language because I wasn't physically
large actually that's a dude thing for
sure and because I think I'm wired to
love underdogs I've always loved them I
think where I've come from
there is no I've ever made it first of
all I don't like the physical things
that's a huge advantage so not needing
to buy a plane or eight thousand dollar
pair of sneakers like there's no
physical thing I want I just like the
awesome Instagram photo that Tyler you
put together the game like I love the
process I'm hungry forever I'm hungry
I'm super hungry I threw up this morning
I'm and I'm theoretically physically I'm
not hungry right now because I'm feeling
a little woozy but emotionally as an
entrepreneur I'm the hungriest it's
incredible I'm dramatically more
successful than I was ten years ago I'm
more hungry not less because because I
just think it was hardwired from the get
I just because I just think it's black
and white I just think at some level
you're just wired the way you are there
is nothing that's gonna fill my appetite
because what drives my hunger is the
process not the results and then by
nature in that construct it goes forever
the only thing that changes my hunger is
if is if the two other most important
variables in this game play themselves
out the health and well-being of my
family or the way I feel about the
allocation of my time and the depth of
that time with my family those are the
only vulnerabilities there's no 14
million dollar you know check or 48
billion dollar check or buying the Jets
like there's nothing that will stop the
hunger when I put my jersey on when I'm
in the context of being a businessman
the hungry you know vibe will be there
forever it's when I'm Gary as a person
where there's other things in my life
besides being on the field that could
play out that could get me to be less
hungry professionally but on the field
I'm going to be a psycho through and
through forever like it that's it great
it's a good show get a job junk I like
you asking joke
so I was just I was just proud I said
episode clean I like messed it up the
last four time I've messed that up the
last four times question of the day tell
me about the end of your summer I've got
a lot of flights coming up and I feel a
little out of touch because we haven't
done this little in a while
vaynernation so this would be a good way
for me to just get a sense for you know
three to four hundred of you that I've
really you know it's funny you guys are
fans of my work and I appreciate that
you'd be shocked how much I'm a fan of
your feedback to my work and who mixes
it up and who like tries to say like
rogue stuff on purpose to gain the
system and who's who's totally into it
now but fades off who's always into it
who comes in and out it's amazing on how
much I know about you even if I don't
know your name you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
[Music]
you
[Music]